If you got 23 for the numerator and 24 for the denominator, you got it right.
Let's see how to get that answer. I know when I add fractions, I have to have
the denominators be the same. So, the first thing that we need to do is find a
common denominator between 12 and 8. Using the factor tree method, I know that 4
is a common factor for both 12 and 8. I know that 4 times 3 is 12. And 4 times 2
gives me 8. So, I can multiply those together, which gives me a common
denominator of 24. The next thing I need to do is create equivalent fractions
that have 24 as the denominator. So, I need to create equivalent fraction for 7
over 12. Since we want to have 24 in the denominator, I know I have to multiply
12 by 2 to get 24 and whatever I multiply the denominator by, I also have to
multiply the numerator by. So, an equivalent fraction for 7/12 is 14 over 24.
Now, let's convert 3/8. We want 24 as the denominator. 8 times 3 gives us 24. 8
times 3 is 24. 3 times 3 is 9. Now, I have an equivalent fraction for 7/12 and I
have an equivalent fraction for 3/8. I can now rewrite the problem using my
equivalent fractions. I have 14 over 24 plus 9 over 24. When I add fractions, I
keep the denominator the same and I add the numerators. 14 and 9 is 23. This
answer is already simplified because there are no factors in common between 23
and 24.